ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 23
zweite und dritte Beratung des von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
temporären Senkung des
Umsatzsteuersatzes auf
Gaslieferungen über das Erdgasnetz die
Fraktion der cdu/csu hat den
Entschließungsantrag auf Drucksache
3758 zurückgezogen damit entfällt
folglich auch die hier ursprünglich
vorgesehene namentliche Abstimmung
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne jetzt die Aussprache
und das Wort hat für die Bundesregierung
der Bundesminister der Finanzen
Christian Lindner
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen guten Morgen
wir befinden uns in einem energiekrieg
Knappheiten beim Gas werden zu einer
Waffe gemacht diese Waffe gibt wird
gegen uns eingesetzt gegen unsere
Wirtschaft gegen die Menschen in diesem
Land das Ziel ist klar es soll unser
Wohlstand erschüttert werden es soll
unsere wirtschaftliche Struktur
getroffen werden um am Ende dafür zu
sorgen dass unser gesellschaftlicher
Zusammenhalt erodiert mit der Absicht
dass die Solidarität dieses Landes
gegenüber der Ukraine endet das ist das
Kalkül von Putin wir senden das klare
Signal aus er wird mit dieser Absicht
scheitern
setzt unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke ein
um die Menschen in diesem Land und
unsere Wirtschaft zu schützen um das zu
bewahren was Menschen sich über
Jahrzehnte aufgebaut haben an
persönlichem aber auch an
gesellschaftlichem Wohlstand unseren
Mittelstand die Industrie all das was
soziale Sicherheit und wirtschaftliche
Stärke in diesem Land ausmacht die
temporäre Senkung auf die Umsatzsteuer
für Gas und im übrigen auch Fernwärme
fügt sich ein in ein Maßnahmepaket dass
die Bundesregierung in den vergangenen
Wochen und auch in dieser Woche am
gestrigen Tag noch einmal präzisiert hat
die Gaspreise steigen und der Staat darf
nicht Profiteur davon sein dass für die
Menschen das Leben teurer wird wir
unternehmen alles
wir unternehmen alles um die Gaspreise
insgesamt zu reduzieren der
Bundeskanzler ist im Ausland unterwegs
um langfristige günstige neue
Lieferquellen zu erschließen wir nutzen
die mit öffentlichen Geld aufgebauten
Gasspeicher jetzt im Winter um ebenfalls
Marktsignale zu senden indem wir auch
wieder
ausspeichern wir sorgen für
Energieeffizienz und wir beraten gerade
heute übrigens auf der europäischen
Ebene über andere gemeinsame Maßnahmen
der Gaspreis muss insgesamt runter aber
er wird immer noch so hoch bleiben dass
er für die Menschen und die Wirtschaft
eine Belastung darstellt und deshalb
leistet der Staat seinen Beitrag dadurch
dass er seine Steuerlast auf diesen
Gaspreis reduziert
wir haben
wir haben wir haben entschieden auch die
Fernwärme mit einzubeziehen in diesem
temporären
diese temporäre Steuersenkung und damit
werden weitere 2,1 Milliarden Euro
Entlastung gesamtstaatlich für die
Laufzeit dieser Maßnahme den Menschen
als Vorteil zu teilen
verehrte anwesende liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen diese Maßnahme heute fügt sich
ein in den von der Bundesregierung
vorgeschlagenen Abwehrschirm gegen
diesen energiekrieg wir mobilisieren 200
Milliarden Euro über die Ertüchtigung
des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds Zweck
und zielgerichtet für Maßnahmen die im
engen Zusammenhang mit dem energiekrieg
stehen es geht nicht darum allgemeine
Vorhaben so wünschenswert sie auch sein
der Ampelkoalition zu verwirklichen
sondern es geht darum jetzt solidarisch
mit den Menschen in diesem Land zu sein
und unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke zu
mobilisieren um sie
für die Zukunft zu erhalten
damit senden wir
damit senden wir gewissermaßen ein
doppeltes Signal das erste Signal ist an
Putin dass wir uns nicht in unserer
Haltung erschüttern lassen sondern dass
wir eine all-in-strategie wählen um
unser Land zu schützen es ist auch eine
zweite Nachricht sondern Nachricht an
die internationalen Kapitalmärkte wir
stellen eine Abwehrschirm auf um uns zu
schützen hinter diesen Abwehrschirm aber
werden wir weiter auch mit den Regeln
der Schuldenbremse Wirtschaften ein
klares Signal an die Kapitalgeber auf
der Welt an diejenigen die deutsche
Staatsanleihen kaufen der Goldstandard
der Staatsfinanzierung wird weiter
Deutschland sein hinter dem Abwehrschirm
bleiben wir solide und damit ist ein
Signal gesendet dass wir in der
Kontinuität der deutschen
staatsstabilitätspolitik verbleiben
werden
hinter diesen Abwehrschirm schützen wir
nicht nur unsere
Staatsfinanzen in der langfristigen
Kontinuität wir erneuern auch unsere
Energieversorgung und bringen alle
Kapazitäten ans Netz die wir haben Kohle
wir beschleunigen die den Zubau der
erneuerbaren von mir sogenannten
freiheitsenergien und wir sind auch
Schritte gegangen um Kernenergie für
diese Krisensituation zu mobilisieren
wir haben zum zum zweiten die
Notwendigkeit unsere Wirtschaft zu
stärken und zu erneuern denn das neue
normalen Niveau der Gaspreise wird höher
sein als das was wir in den vergangenen
Jahren und Jahrzehnten gehabt haben wir
nutzen also jetzt den Abwehrschirm mit
der temporären Subventionierung von
Energie inklusive Senkung von
Umsatzsteuer um dahinter das deutsche
Geschäftsmodell zu erneuern dafür
mobilisieren wir auch im Bundeshaushalt
rekordinvestitionen aber das alleine
wird nicht reichen die Wirtschaft
muss sich ja Erneuern der Beitrag den
die Politik dazu leisten kann ist sie
nicht zusätzlich zu beschweren und zu
fesseln und deshalb gehört zu diesen
Abwehrschirm
und deshalb gehört zu diesem
Abwehrschirm liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auch das zumindest die
Bundesregierung auf
unverhältnismäßige zusätzliche
Bürokratielasten während der Zeit der
Krise verzichten will wir haben einen
belastungsmoratorium verabredet ich
glaube sinnvoll wäre über den Verzicht
auf zusätzliche Belastung auch die
gegenwärtigen Belastungen und Fässern in
den Blick zu nehmen da gibt es noch
unverändert viel zu tun was uns brennt
bremst alleine beim fuel Switch beim
Wechsel von Energieträgern haben wir
unverändert so viel bürokratische
Fesseln die uns bei der Transformation
Bremsen es wäre ein guter Rat an uns
diese Fesseln zu lösen vielen Dank
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
hat hier eingeführt temporäre
umsatzsteuersenkung auf Gaslieferung die
wird es nämlich geben obwohl es die
gasumlage nicht gibt es war ja mal ein
jungtim aber jetzt hat die Regierung
gesagt wir entlasten die Bürger auch an
dieser Stelle Matthias Mittelberg jetzt
für die Union heute
diskutieren die Absenkung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas ist richtig
wir hätten das schon viel früher
diskutieren können denn wir haben das
hier im Hause schon als cdu/csu-fraktion
im Februar beantragt da waren sie damals
noch dagegen
das ist jetzt
dieses Ding ist jetzt dann irgendwie die
Notlösung gewesen weil sie dann
festgestellt haben dass sie mit der
gasumlage die Verbraucher zusätzlich
belasten und dann haben sie sich was
überlegt wie sie diese Belastung durch
eine gewisse Entlastung wieder
ausgleichen können dadurch haben wir
jetzt hier diese Debatte aber immerhin
das ganze beruht auf ihrer
Fehlkonstruktion gasumlage das haben sie
jetzt glücklicherweise erkannt ich will
gar nicht die ganze Geschichte wieder
hervorrufen zweimal haben wir hier die
gasumlage zur Abstimmung gestellt
zweimal haben sie für ihre gasumlage
gestimmt jetzt haben Sie erkannt dass
die gasumlage ja was soll man sagen Mist
ist untauglich ist eine Fehlkonstruktion
ist sie beerdigen heute ihre gasumlage
einen Tag bevor sie morgen in Kraft
getreten wäre und sind stattdessen zu
der Auffassung gekommen eine
gaspreisbremse einer Entlastung der
Bürger sei sinnvoll dazu allerdings
sagen wir dann tatsächlich herzlichen
Glückwunsch wir hätten uns gewünscht
diese Erkenntnis wer ihnen doch früher
gekommen und zwar deutlich früher
so diese Entlastung der Verbraucher die
heute hier zur Debatte steht ist wichtig
aber eine ein großer Wurf ist dieser
Schritt nun tatsächlich nicht der
Bundeskanzler nee ich also es ist so wie
es ist die Gaspreise der Bundeskanzler
hat doch hier vorgerechnet es wäre jetzt
eine ganz tolle Entlastung und das ist
natürlich völliger Käse weil die Leute
sind jetzt mit dem drei vier fünffachen
Gaspreis konfrontiert und wenn sie
vorher eine Gasrechnung hatten mit 1000
Euro und haben darauf 19% Mehrwertsteuer
gezahlt dann mussten sie 190 Euro
Mehrwertsteuer zahlen wenn sie jetzt die
dreimal so hohe Gasrechnung von 3000
Euro haben dann zahlen Sie zwar nur 7%,
das sind dann aber 210 Euro
Mehrwertsteuer das heißt die Zahlen am
Ende sogar mehr Mehrwertsteuer und das
ist ja ihr Problem dass sie permanent
nicht verstehen dass sie an dieser irren
Inflation die stattfindet
an dieser wahnsinnigen Inflation die
stattfindet haben sie doch permanent
massive Mehreinnahmen das müssten Sie
dem Bürger mal ehrlich sagen also in
vielen Bereichen brauchen Sie gar keine
Schulden machen sondern sie müssen nur
intelligent mit den Mehreinnahmen
umgehen und die nicht ständig in
Gießkannen Programmen verpassen
so
und jetzt kommen wir mal jetzt kommen
wir mal zum eigentlichen Kern sie haben
da jetzt ja ein ganz tolles
sechsseitiges Papier vorgelegt der eine
sagt Abwehrschirm der andere sagt
doppelwumms da müssen sie sich jetzt
noch einigen über die Terminologie in
erster Linie in erster Linie ist dieses
Papier zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nichts
anderes als ein schuldenwumms das sage
ich Ihnen mal ganz deutlich wir haben
200 Milliarden neue Schulden die Sie ins
Schaufenster gestellt haben was sie aber
damit finanzieren wollen ist völlig
unklar es gibt auch gar keine
Kalkulation oder irgendeine
Berechnungsgrundlage die nachvollziehbar
wäre
in den entscheidenden Punkten in den
entscheidenden Punkten
gaspreisbremse ich meine immerhin haben
sie das jetzt erkannt dass sie eine
Preisbremse brauchen und keine Umlage
dazu noch mal herzlichen Glückwunsch
nach vielen Wochen und Monaten aber
wie sie jetzt diese gaspreisumlage
umgestalten wollen konkret da steht doch
nichts in ihrem Papier wie die
strompreisbremse aussehen soll da steht
nichts in ihrem Papier wie sie jetzt
konkret Betriebe und Unternehmen stützen
wollen in der Krise wie viel Geld die zu
erwarten haben wie viel preisentlastung
dazu steht nichts in ihrem Papier das
ist leider die Wirklichkeit dann führe
ich eben mit ihrem Kollegen von der FDP
draußen in Interview der dann noch sagt
die Kernkraftwerke müssen weiterlaufen
alles klar aber dazu steht nichts in
ihrem Papier wir sie haben gestern um
das noch mal klar zu sagen nichts
anderes als 200 Milliarden
schulden-präsentiert wir warten jetzt
aber immer noch auf den Wumms der dann
irgendwann kommt wo sie konkret sagen
welche Maßnahmen sie damit finanzieren
und umsetzen wollen und wie sie die
Bürger in diesem Land entlasten wollen
das weiß bis zur Stunde keine Socke das
ist die Wirklichkeit sie haben Fehler
über Fehler gemacht bisher in dieser
Krise und das ist wirklich traurig genug
das muss man einfach mal in Erinnerung
rufen sie haben den ganzen Sommer über
verdaddelt mit ihren internen
Streitereien jetzt verweisen sie auf
ihre Expertenkommission ja die hätten
doch schon längst fertig sein können mit
der Arbeit die hätten sie schon vor
Wochen einsetzen können dann hätten wir
die konkreten Vorschläge auf dem Tisch
und die richtige Reihenfolge wer doch
gewesen sie hätten die Experten arbeiten
lassen die machen Vorschläge und dann
unterhalten wir uns darüber was die
Vorschläge Kosten jetzt sind sie doch
panisch den anderen wie ich gegangen
weil sie gesehen haben oh Gott da kommt
jetzt die gasumlage diesen Blödsinn den
wir beschlossen haben der tritt morgen
in Kraft und deswegen müssen wir in
dieser Woche ganz schnell panisch noch
einen anderen Finanzierungsweg aufzeigen
deswegen sind sie doch in diese Panik
verfallen in dieser Woche diese
Pressekonferenz zu machen wo sie nichts
Konkretes mitteilen außer dass sie 200
Milliarden Schulden machen diese Aktion
hätte komplett anders rumlaufen müssen
sie hätten jetzt ganz konkret sagen
müssen was machen sie gaspreisbremse was
machen Sie konkret mit der
strompreisbremse wie fördern sie die
Unternehmen in Deutschland wie machen
sie wirklich diesen Abwehrschirm konkret
und dann hätten sie sagen müssen wie
kriegen wir jetzt ganz zügig mehr
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz um das Angebot
zu vergrößern was machen wir ganz
konkret mit den Kernkraftwerken und da
sage ich Ihnen auch
das ist naiv und unverantwortlich gerade
was die Grünen in Niedersachsen machen
das sage ich Ihnen mal ganz deutlich wir
sind in der größten Energiekrise Europas
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in dieser
Situation darf man überhaupt nicht auf
die Idee kommen auch nur irgendein
Kraftwerk abzuschalten und zwar völlig
egal wie es Betrieben ist ob mit Kohle
mit Kernkraft spielt überhaupt gar keine
Rolle sie dürfen jetzt kein einziges
Kraftwerk abschalten das ist die
Wirklichkeit
der nächste der nächste Winter wird
schon heftig genug der übernächste wird
wahrscheinlich noch heftiger werden weil
wir dann nämlich nicht volle Speicher
haben die wir noch mit russischem Gas
voll füllen konnten und deswegen ist es
noch unverantwortlicher wenn sie jetzt
Kraftwerke abstellen wollen wir warten
immer noch auf Ihre konkreten Vorschläge
wie sie das Problem lösen wollen bisher
ist nur schuldenwumms und keine
konkreten Vorschläge
Matthias Mittelberg stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Union es ist
bisher nur Schulden Wumms hat er gesagt
und er selber muss man noch dazu sagen
kommt aus Niedersachsen und in der Tat
diese niedersächsische Landtagswahl
spielt ja bei der ein oder anderen
Überlegung sicherlich auch immer noch
eine Hauptrolle Tim küssendorf jetzt
Finanzausschuss mit die SPD
lieber dr Mittelberg ich hatte es schon
in der letzten Sitzungswoche gesagt dass
ich mich eigentlich immer freue in der
Debatte auf ihre Vorschläge einzugehen
und ich kann mich nur wiederholen auch
in dieser Debatte habe ich keinen
einzigen Vorschlag vor ihnen gehört wie
sie das besser machen würden
sie haben uns insgesamt drei
Vorwürfe gemacht der erste Vorwurf ist
wir handeln zu langsam in Anbetracht
dessen was ich von ihrer Fraktion in
diesem gesamten Jahr an Vorschlägen
gehört habe kann ich nur sagen hätten
wir all dem zugestimmt dann wäre diese
Haushalt nicht nur mehrfach überzeichnet
sondern die Maßnahmen würden sich alle
auch noch widersprechen wir können
dankbar sein dass wir unserem
strategischen gut organisierten Weg
gefolgt sind und nicht ihren Vorschlägen
und einer ein weiterer Punkt der Vorwurf
dass wir zu langsam sind entbehrt doch
jeglicher Grundlage wir haben in diesem
Jahr bereits wenn ich das jetzt noch als
weiteres entlassungspaket dazu zähle was
gestern vereinbart worden ist haben wir
das vierte Entlastungspaket
verabschiedet wir sind insgesamt
mittlerweile bei fast 300 Milliarden
Euro ich weiß nicht von welcher
Regierung sie mehr verlangen würden wir
handeln entschlossen schlagkräftig und
schnell und wir tun was für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
und das entkräftet nämlich genauso auch
den Vorwurf dass das kein großer Wurf
sei ich erinnere mich noch gut wo wir im
Februar hier standen oder Bundeskanzler
das Sondervermögen in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr
verkündet hat bei ihnen war hier
Volksfeststimmung bei 200 Milliarden
Euro für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger für
die Unternehmen ist das kein großer Wurf
ich weiß nicht in welchen Dimensionen
sie denken das ist deutlich ein großer
Wurf und eine wirksame Entlastung
und zum letzten Punkt wir benennen keine
Details ohne jetzt noch mal auf die
Kommission hinzuweisen oder ähnliches
ich erinnere mich nur an ihren Vorschlag
zu Inflationsausgleich zu dem Antrag der
wurde in der Anhörung zerrissen und wir
wissen alle wie Anhörung funktionieren
und wieder Experten eingeladen werden
der wurde unisono zerrissen alle ihre
Vorschläge haben weder Details noch
Inhalte bitte vertrauen Sie dieser
Bundesregierung sie handelt gut und
richtig schnell und schlagkräftig
jetzt habe ich leider nur noch die
Hälfte meiner Redezeit übrig ich wollte
eigentlich so viel sagen noch zum
Mehrwertsteuersenkung
grundsätzlich freue ich mich wirklich
und das meine ich jetzt ganz ernst dass
die Entlastung auch über die
Mehrwertsteuer noch weiterhin Bestand
hat denn natürlich mit dem Abwehrschirm
den wir gestern vereinbart haben in der
großen Koalition in einer apfelkoalition
haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen
vereinbart aber vor allen Dingen unter
Punkt 6 auch weiterhin die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung entlastet die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger direkt und vor
allen Dingen schon ab dem 1 Oktober das
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt weil die
Heizperiode jetzt beginnt und die
wirksame Entlastung jetzt schon Eintritt
und ich
und ich freue mich auch dass es uns im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gelungen ist
der Bundesfinanzminister hat es gesagt
dass wir auch die Fernwärme dazu
ergänzen konnten denn gerade in
Ostdeutschland gibt es einfach eine
ganze Menge von Haushalten die über
Fernwärme beheizt werden ich denke da
zum Beispiel an Städte wie Zwickau wo
über die Hälfte aller Haushalte über
Fernwärme beheizt werden und ich glaube
auch diese zusätzlichen 2,1 Milliarden
Euro sind noch mal ein ganz wichtiger
Schritt zu Entlastung
insgesamt sind das also rund 13
Milliarden Euro Entlastung über die
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger direkt erreichen
und die zusätzlich zum Abwehr Schirm
wirken ich glaube insgesamt ist das
wirklich ein gutes ein gutes Gesetz was
nicht nur ab 1 Oktober gilt sondern was
auch ein Umfang hat von dem man wirklich
sprechen kann dass es ein großer Wurf
ist und ein weiterer Punkt ist ja auch
in diesem Gesetz ja noch untergebracht
worden deswegen möchte ich Ihnen gerne
noch erwähnen und zwar ist dass die
Steuerbefreiung für die
inflationsausgleichsprämie und wir haben
ja viel darüber gesprochen dass
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgeber
möglicherweise auch nicht in der Lage
sind im Moment diese ausgleichsprämie zu
bezahlen da möchte ich ganz gerne noch
mal einen Artikel zitieren den ich vor
zwei Tagen glaube ich gelesen habe die
deutschen Dax-Konzerne haben ihre
Vorstandsgehälter im letzten Jahr um 25%
erhöht das Argument dass die Unternehmen
in Deutschland nicht in der Lage sind
eine inflationsausgleichsprämie zu
zahlen die wir heute Steuer befreit
machen zählt für mich nicht wer in der
Lage ist Vorstände mit 25% zu bezahlen
der muss auch in der Lage sein für die
breite Belegschaft inflations-
[Applaus]
insgesamt sprechen wir also hier von
einer
von der AFD das sind wirklich die letzte
Fraktion von der ich Vorschläge brauche
also vielen Dank Herr Gottschalk
insgesamt sprechen wir hier also von
einem Gesetzespaket was auf der einen
Seite die umsatzsteuersenkung hat auf
der anderen Seite die Steuerbefreiung
für die Einmalzahlung es sich einfügt in
ein Abwehrschirm der gestern vereinbart
worden ist ich kann mich nur wiederholen
diese Regierung löst ihr Versprechen ein
wir haben versprochen wir lassen
niemanden in diesem Land allein und das
lösen wir hier mit allen vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit
Tim klyssendorf von der SPD aber seine
Äußerungen strategisch gut organisierter
Weg den wir gefolgt sind da mussten
selbst viele Ampel Koalitionäre Lächeln
Klaus Söder jetzt für die AFD erst
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss
ja sehr geile frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Gäste auf der
Tribüne lassen mich kurz auf dem
Verfahrensweg dieses Gesetzes eingehen
also ich habe ja durchaus Verständnis
dafür dass regieren im Moment nicht
gerade einfach ist aber es hat sich auch
keiner gezwungen dieses Amt anzunehmen
anstatt den letzten drei Jahren ein
rot-grünes ideologieprojekt umzusetzen
müssen sich mit der größten
Wirtschaftskrise der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik befassen und man muss
feststellen sind damit total überfordert
sie bringen
sie bringen während der
finanzausschusssitzung ein
änderungseintrag ein den keiner kennt
sie setzen drei Stunden nach der Sitzung
eine Sondersitzung ein weil ihn
plötzlich einfällt dass sie die
Fernwärme vergessen haben das ist auch
unprofessionell und damit zeigen Sie
auch dass Sie auf die Sachverständigen
Anhörung überhaupt nicht gehört haben
denn dort war dieser Punkt explizit
angesprochen sie hätten also genug Zeit
gehabt bis Mittwoch 10 Uhr diesen Punkt
einzuarbeiten haben sie nicht gemacht
das zeigt auch dass sie die Anhörung für
sie ein reiner Alibi-Veranstaltung sind
das finde ich echt traurig für
Demokratie
und das im Gesetzentwurf die Laufzeit
der umsatzsteuersenkung immer noch an
die gasumlage knüpft ist die ja nun
wahrscheinlich oder höchstwahrscheinlich
wegfällt ist nicht nur ein
handwerklicher Fehler trotzdem stimmen
wir diesen Gesetzentwurf zu weil ein
erster Schritt ist und zumindest die
Privathaushalte Kommunen Krankenhäuser
und so weiter von hohen Gaskosten zu
entlasten auch die inflationspauschale
von 3000 Euro stimmen wir zu und Herr
Kollege Klüssendorf dass sie sich als
SPD-Mitglied an den DAX-Konzern
orientieren das finde ich schon
erstaunlich ne ich Frage nämlich ist ob
alle Unternehmen insbesondere die
kleinen Unternehmen in der Lage sind
diese pauschalen zu zahlen da haben mich
sehr viele jetzt inzwischen angerufen
und sagt was beschließen wir da wir
werden natürlich von Spritkosten und
Energiekosten geplagt und eine
Arbeitnehmer sehr schnell ihre
chefsfragen wann bekomme ich denn diese
3000 Euro ausgezahlt und der
Kleinunternehmer wird sagen ja weil ich
dir gerne zahlen kann aber leider gerade
zwei große Strom am Gasrechnung bei mir
auf dem Schreibtisch liegen und kann dir
das im Moment nicht auszahlen und das
geht
spielen so das hat sehr viel Frust
auslösen und wir können eigentlich nur
hoffen dass bis Ende 2024 jeder diese
Pauschale erhalten hat
und da sind wir bei den Unternehmen
insbesondere die bereits seit Anfang des
Jahres durch die hohen Spritpreise und
nur durch die exorbitanten Energie und
Gaspreise belastet sind den hilft ihre
umsatzsteuersenkung überhaupt nicht und
je nachdem wie Energie dieses
Unternehmen sind stehen inzwischen viele
vor dem Aus in meinen Wahlkreis müssen
heute am 30 September drei Bäckereien
alles Familienbetriebe schließen in
kahler und Triptis geht einem mehr als
55-Jährige Tradition der
Porzellanindustrie in Thüringen am Ende
des Jahres zu Ende was haben sie mit
dieser Unternehmen für Hilfsangebote
jetzt 200 Milliardenpaket da bin ich
sehr gespannt kommen wir zurück zum
Carsten Strompreis sie bekämpfen mit
ihren teuren entlassungspaketen nur die
Symptome aber nicht die Ursachen
zu diesen Ursachen gehört eben auch ihre
total verkorkste Energiepolitik es ist
eben ein und Dingen anzunehmen man
können da industriestand wie Deutschland
ausschließlich mit Windkraft und Solar
am Leben erhalten
während weltweit neue moderne
Atomkraftwerke gebaut werden wollen sie
letzten HKW in Deutschland abschalten
dabei der Chef des TÜV ausdrücklich
festgestellt dass wohl die aktuelle
laufenden AKW weil er betrieben werden
können als auch mit relativ kurzer
Anlaufzeit die letzten Jahr
abgeschalteten AKW wie ganz nett gehen
könnten aber ihm geht grüne Ideologie
vor Vernunft und vor allem gegen die
Interessen des deutschen Volkes das ist
auf das ist auf die Regierung gezogen
sie können uns ruhig sein das ist auf
die Regierung bezogen ein Prognose
wir müssen hier auch über Russland und
Sanktion sprechen es macht wirklich
extrem
da ist er hat mich als Fünfte Kolonne
und zukünftigen Pressesprecher von Putin
tituliert eins will ich mal klarstellen
ja Kollege klüsendorf
die nicht als Demokraten und hier
Vorurteile auch den Angriff auf die
Ukraine als völkerrechtswidrig aber
welcher Krieg ist der nicht
völkerrechtswidrig etwa der Krieg der
USA ein Vietnam oder landgriff auf den
Irak war das völkerrechtswidrig ich
denke schon wenn du solche Einstufungen
vornehmen
damit auch für alle
ich war am Sonntag auf einer
Veranstaltung in der Kirchen von Rodheim
und mein Heimatort hat das super intent
der evangelischen Kirche in Eisenach
gesagt es gibt keine gerechten es gibt
keine ungerechten Kriege bei Kriege
bedeuten immer nur tot und Zerstörungen
und den schließe ich mich hundertprozent
an was bringen diese Sanktionen seriöse
Wirtschaftsinstitute gehen davon aus
dass das Bruttoinlandsprodukt in
Russland in diesem Jahr um fünf bis acht
Prozent zurückgeht das ist nicht
wesentlich mehr als das der Einbruch im
Corona Jahr 2020 in Deutschland und wo
wir so wie wir Corona 2020 überstanden
haben so steht auch Russland dieses
Sanktionen
übrigens gehen die kleinen
Wirtschaftsinstitute inzwischen davon
aus dass wir im nächsten Jahr ein
Rückgang von 7,9% zu verkraften haben
7,9%. da kann ich nur sagen herzlichen
Glückwunsch und die haben will
und die auf die Auswirkungen auf die
einheimischen Firmen durch die
russlandsaktionen gehen sie überhaupt
nicht ein ich kenne sehr viele Firmen
gerade hier bei uns in Ostdeutschland
die sehr enge wirtschaftsbeziehung
sowohl den Ukraine als auch nach
Russland haben und die stehen im Moment
vor leeren Kassen ja weil sie will
aufgrund des Krieges nicht in Ukrain
exportieren können und aufgrund der
Sanktionen auch nicht nach Russland
exportieren können das ist aber von
ihnen vollkommen ausgeblendet
und über die sogar Sabotage bei
Nordstemmen freuen sich bestimmt einige
Abgeordnete hier im Saal aber vor allen
Dingen die USA welche unsere bisher
guten Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu Russland
immer schon ein Dorn im Auge waren aber
nun geht es keine Alternative mehr wir
müssen das teure Flüssigkeit aus den USA
und anderswo einkaufen und Kassel Scholz
und Mister Habig vor dem Star
ging es doch nicht auf sind aber gar
nicht fertig
Kassler Scholz und Minister Habeck nein
jetzt auf Einkaufstour unter anderem
Katar Katar das muss man sich echt mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen wir
brechen die Beziehung zum Diktator Putin
ab und lassen uns von einer Diktatur mit
Flüssiggas und Öl beliefern Team wissen
gar nicht was Menschenrechte sind Frauen
dürfen ohne Zustimmung ihres Mannes
überhaupt gar nichts machen Frauen unter
25 dürfen nicht aus ihren Haus ausziehen
ohne Zustimmung aus Mannes frauen dürfen
Unia Zustimmung nicht keine Reisen
antreten ja eine Frau die eine
Vergewaltigung anzeigt riskiert eine
Gefängnisstrafe
homosexualität wird ja hier so
propagiert seine Straftat wird mit 100
peitschenheben und bis zu sieben Jahren
Gefängnis bestraft und die rund 300.000
Kataris
[Musik]
das hat was damit zu tun sie kaufen der
sie kaufen ja jetzt Gas ein von Ländern
die hier nicht demokratisch stellen das
müssen sich mal anhören ja und die
Krauthausen Kataris Beuten 3 Millionen
Gastarbeiter aus wann und diese ist
Sklaven das ist nicht mein Speck das ist
nicht meine Information das kannst Du
nachlesen vor der Woche Sendung
Kontraste und das sind nun unsere neuen
Handelspartner von denen Minister Habeck
ein Bückling macht schämen sie sich für
seine Schande für die deutsche
Außenpolitik
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
möchte zum Schluss noch ein Wort sagen
kriegt ihr dann einen Kollegen Merz sie
hatten sich ja so intensiv mit den
Tumult des Demonstrationen
auseinandersetzen und diese denunziert
ich kann Ihnen eines sagen das sind
keine afd-leute die dort rumlaufen in
ganz normale Bürger auch die du
Mitglieder ganz viele kommen Sie mal
nach Eisenach werden sie keine afd-fahne
sehen einfach nur Burger die die
Schleuse voll haben von ihrer Politik
vielen Dank
die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gaslieferung soll
gesenkt werden auf
7%, also dort eine Entlastung für die
Bürger obwohl es die gasumlage nicht
mehr gibt ursprünglich war das ja mal
ein jungtim aber die Bundesregierung hat
sich entschieden diese Senkung
durchzuführen darüber diskutiert der
Bundestag und jetzt Katharina Beck die
finanzpolitische sprech an der
bündnisgründen Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zur CDU nur erst
uns von Putins Gas abhängig machen dann
unfassbar viel fordern und überhaupt
nicht sagen wie das finanziert werden
soll das ist unseriös zum Thema die
Gaspreise und die Energiekosten müssen
jetzt sinken 40% der Menschen in
Deutschland haben keine Rücklagen 33
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland haben
also keinen Puffer jetzt hunderte von
Euro mehr kosten zu stemmen diese krasse
energiepreiskrise trifft Menschen mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen
deutlich härter als andere und das ist
wichtig immer vor Augen zu haben
die ca 13 Milliarden schwere befristete
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas- und
Fernwärme kann einen Beitrag zur
Entlastung leisten bei vollständiger
Weitergabe an die endverbraucherinnen
würden die Preise um ca 10% gedämpft das
ist gut aber die Preisentwicklung ist
viel extremer die Verbraucherpreise beim
Gas sind im September außerordentliche
230 Prozent gestiegen dramatisch vor
allem für die vielen ohne Rücklagen und
daher ist es so gut dass die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung Teil eines
größeren Konzepts ist nach bisher 95
Milliarden in drei entlastungspaketen
hat die Regierung gestern einen 200
Milliarden Euro schweren Abwehrschirm
vorgeschlagen mit dem der Gas- und
stromkreiskrise auf der Angebotsseite
das ist so wichtig mit nie dagewesenen
preisbremsen begegnet werden soll
neben dem herausragenden Kraftakt den
herausragenden Kraftakt die Gasspeicher
trotz Putin zu füllen nun ein weiterer
entscheidender Schritt dieser Ampel und
es ist sehr gut dass bei der
strompreisbremse klar nur ein
basisverbrauch und zwar für kleinere
mittlere Einkommen kein subventioniert
werden soll und bei der gasbremse
ähnliches vorgesehen ist und auch das
zufallsgewinne der Stromproduzenten bei
der strompreisbremse zur Finanzierung
herangezogen werden das ist ein sehr
guter Mechanismus der breiten
Finanzierung und wir drücken dem
Wirtschaftsminister die Daumen denn
diesen Momenten beim eu-energieminister
Treffen verhandelt dass eine
funktionierende Abschöpfung der
übergewinne auf der fossilen Energien
beschlossen wird
der Energien die diese Preiskrise
überhaupt erst ausgelöst haben
diese übergewinne werden unter anderem
auch auf dem Rücken der Autofahrerinnen
und Autofahrer erhoben die nach wie vor
fast 50 Prozent an zusätzlicher
Gewinnmarge mehr zahlen müssen als
früher und zwar nur wegen der Marktmacht
die wir nun auch endlich mit dem
Kartellrecht angehen werden
nochmal zur Umsatzsteuer der
Gasverbrauch in Deutschland erfolgt zu
zwei Dritteln durch die Wirtschaft und
die Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf den
Gaspreis kommt bei den unter den Preisen
bleibenden kleinst- und Kleinunternehmen
bei den Selbstständigen und Mittelstand
leider nicht an denn die Mehrwertsteuer
ist für sie ein durchlaufender Posten
und auch deswegen ist es so wichtig dass
die Finanzierung für das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm und für die Hilfen für
kleinere und mittlere Unternehmen nun
durch den Abwehrschirm gesichert ist
hier wollen und werden wir nun sehr
schnell ins Handeln kommen wir haben im
Bundestag mit dafür gesorgt dass für die
VerbraucherInnen Fernwärme auch
begünstigt besteuert wird rund 6
Millionen Haushalte werden in
Deutschland mit Fernwärme geheizt der
Großteil Mietwohnungen und gerade die
ist wichtig zu entlasten trotzdem muss
man objektiv sagen
umsatzsteuersenkungen sind weder
ökonomisch noch sozial die besten
Instrumente zu entlasten dass sie an die
VerbraucherInnen weitergegeben wird das
kann der Staat leider nicht garantieren
und außerdem entlastet man die die viel
verbrauchen und tendenziell mehr Geld
mehr als die die wenig verbrauchen und
tendenziell weniger Geld haben trotzdem
ist das Gesamtpaket sehr sehr gut und
auch wenn es nach einem solch großen
Betrag gestern seltsam klingen mag ich
muss leider warnen dass wir weiter
schauen ob wir die vielen Millionen
Menschen die überhaupt keine Rücklagen
haben ausreichend unterstützen sie
brauchen es am meisten da müssen wir
weiter darauf achten ich freue mich auf
die weitere sehr gute konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit mit meinen
ampelpartner:innen und meiner Fraktion
vielen Dank
Katherine big von den bündnisgrün war
dass sie es auch stellvertretende
Vorsitzende das Finanzausschusses
nächster Redner Christian leyhe für die
linke Fraktion spricht der erste
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meiner
Damen und Herren was ein Chaos zuerst
lassen Sie sich ein Gesetz von den
Energiekonzernen schreiben damit die
Bürger für deren Ausfälle mit der
gasumlage Blechen sollen dann wollen sie
die Umsatzsteuer auf die gasumlage
weglassen damit ihn niemand vorwerfen
kann der Staat verdient daran auch noch
dann muss ihnen die EU sagen das dürfen
sie gar nicht also beschließen sie eine
umsatzsteuerreduzierung für alles Gas
und verkaufen das als in großen
Ausgleich zur gasumlage verschweigen
aber das ein Drittel der Haushalte
trotzdem draufzahlen muss dann machen
sie das ganze auch noch so schlecht dass
gar nicht alle Gaskunden betroffen sind
und dann erwarten sie dass die Konzerne
die Steuersenkung eins zu eins
weitergeben obwohl wir doch beim
Tankdeckel gelernt haben dass das nicht
funktionieren tut wenn es um viel Geld
geht bei Konzernen und dann nur zwei
Tage vor der Einführung der gasumlage
fällt der Groschen und sie Anliegen
diese Schnapsidee endlich meine Damen
und Herren
es ist gut dass die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die Menschen
entlastet und es ist gut dass sie auch
auf Druck aus meiner Fraktion
aufgenommen haben das Fernwärme
dazugehört aber wegen diesem Chaos und
wegen den handwerklichen Schnitzern
werden wir uns heute enthalten müssen
und halten wir fest in der schlimmsten
Energiekrise der Bundesrepublik spielt
die ampelregierung absoluten
kreisliga-fußball und die Hälfte der
Mannschaft weiß nicht mal auf welches
Tor sie schießen soll man Damen und
Herren
wir haben hier den gaspreisdeckel
gefordert sie haben geschimpft jetzt
übernehmen sie die Idee wir haben hier
eine übergewinnsteuer gefordert sie
haben geschimpft jetzt übernehmen sie
die Idee zum Teil und nennen es eine
strompreisbremse wir haben hier eine
staatliche Preiskontrolle gefordert und
wie sie geschimpft haben und ich
prognostiziere Ihnen Sie werden eine
Preiskontrolle einführen müssen bei
einem gaspreisdeckel oder wollen Sie den
Energiekonzern einfach so die Milliarden
überweisen ohne zu gucken ob das eine
Richtigkeit hat und wo wir gerade dabei
sind wir haben gegen die Schuldenbremse
geredet sie haben dagegen gehalten und
heute ist die Schuldenbremse faktisch
tot sie ist tot sie ist beerdigt die
Trauergäste sind auf dem Weg nach auch
nach Hause nur Christian Lindner steht
noch an ihrem Grabe und versucht sich
mit ihr für 2023 zu verabreden tragisch
ist dass Herr Lindner nehmen sie
Abschied
so und auch wenn Sie unsere Konzepte
teilweise übernehmen die Wahrheit ist
doch Winter ist coming und sie haben
keine vernünftige Strategie für die
kalte Jahreszeit und warum nicht noch im
Juni erklärte Minister Habig eine
Deckelung der Preise wäre bei einem
knappen Gut ein Signal Energie ist nicht
wertvoll Haut raus was ihr wollt heißt
übersetzt sie wollten die hohen Preise
damit die Menschen sich die Heizung
nicht leisten können damit sie Gas
sparen weil nicht genug Gas da ist heißt
aber im Umkehrschluss wenn sie jetzt
ihre Strategie ändern wenn Sie den
gaspreisdeckel vernünftig machen steht
die Frage im Raum haben wir in diesem
Wirtschaftskrieg eigentlich genug Gas
für alle werden wir im Winter genug Gas
für alle haben ja oder nein und deswegen
hoffen Sie auch auf einen warmen Winter
in Deutschland und sie hoffen auf einen
warmen Winter in Norwegen die größte
Volkswirtschaft Europas hofft auf eine
gute Wetterprognose damit hier nicht das
Licht ausgeht und damit hier nicht
tausende Menschen Arbeitsplätze
verlieren ich sage Ihnen etwas was da
draußen alle Menschen schon wissen dass
hoffen auf eine gute Wetterprognose
ersetzt keine Strategie in Energie-
dieser Wirtschaftskrieg geht für die
eigene Bevölkerung immer mehr nach
hinten los und ich kenne da draußen
außerhalb der politikblase nicht einen
Menschen buchstäblich nicht einen
einzigen Menschen der nicht weiß dass
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
der Wirtschaftskrieg und die aktuelle
Energiekrise zusammengehören alle
Menschen wissen das sie werden über die
Sanktionen reden müssen sie halten das
in diesem winterpolitisch nicht durch
das fliegt ihnen um die Ohren und
deswegen komme ich zum Schluss diese
Gesellschaft braucht Heizung Brot und
Frieden Heizung Brot und Frieden darum
geht es um diesen Winter danke schön
Kassen Leihe ja noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass auf der Angebotsseite
Energie dringend etwas passieren muss
denn in der Tat besteht ja die Gefahr
wie auch immer finanziert das ist zu
wenig Energie in Deutschland geben kann
Tillmann jetzt für die FDP
innen und Kollegen
seit Monaten verfolgen der tagtäglich
wieder russische Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine zu unendlich viel Leid bei den
Betroffenen vor Ort führt jeden Tag
sterben hunderte von Menschen Familien
werden getrennt das Resultat von Leben
harter Arbeit wird zerstört das alles im
Zuge eines sinnlosen Krieges für den
hauptsächlich einen einziger Mann die
Verantwortung trägt wenn derartiges
Unrecht stattfindet dürfen wir das nicht
einfach hinnehmen für uns Freie
Demokraten war deshalb von Anfang an
klar dass die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnen
muss und Finanzminister Christian
lindert auch gerade klar gemacht dass
das im Kern von dem steht was wir heute
ja auch wirtschaftlich machen wollen wir
lassen nicht zu dass unser Land durch
hohe Energiepreise gespalten wird
die Energiepreisentwicklung der
vergangenen Monate führt uns deutlich
vor Augen in was für eine unsägliche
Abhängigkeit die verfehlte
Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahre uns
geführt hat und lieber Kollege
Mittelberg davon haben sie leider nichts
gesagt wer dafür verantwortlich ist
nun benutzt Russland Energie als Waffe
gegen uns mit weiteren Gaslieferungen
aus Russland ist endgültig nicht mehr zu
rechnen die Situation spielt sich
deshalb täglich weiter zu und der
gestern von Bundeskanzler Scholz im
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
angekündigte wirtschaftliche
Abwehrschirm gegen die Folgen des
russischen angriffskriegs nimmt eine
zentrale Rolle bei der Bewältigung
dieses enorm dieser enorm
Herausforderungen an die Ampelkoalition
beweist damit ein weiteres Mal
Handlungsfähigkeit in einer schweren
Krise
der vorliegende Gesetzesentwurf der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferung und Fernwärme ist ein
wichtiger Teil eben dieses
angesprochenen abwehrschirms die
derzeitigen Kosten beim gasbelasten eben
nicht nur den Staat und die Betriebe
sondern auch die vielen privaten
Haushalte in unserem Land immer mehr
Menschen erreichen in diesen Tagen
Briefe mit unerfreundlichen Nachrichten
übersteigende Abschlagszahlungen viele
fragen sich wie das noch bezahlbar sein
soll wenn sich die Preise innerhalb
weniger Monate so stark erhöhen um es
deutlich zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
handeln damit die Bürger unseres Landes
gut durch den Winter kommen
mit dem vorliegenden Gesetzesentwurf
entlasten wir Millionen Menschen um über
13 Milliarden Euro 13 Milliarden Euro
mehr in den Taschen der Steuerzahler wo
sie mit Blick auf die kommenden Monate
auch am besten aufgehoben sind deshalb
appelliere ich sie an dieser Stelle
liebe Kollegen dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf zuzustimmen sodass wir
die Entlastung der Bürger schnell auf
den Weg bringen können vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Alois reiner
alles Rainer von der CSU ist der
Vorsitzende des Finanzausschusses
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben diese
Woche sehr ausführlich lange im
Ausschuss über die Mehrwertsteuersenkung
auf Gast diskutiert dann kam nach
Beschlussfassung die Bitte um eine
Sondersitzung weil wir auch die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Fernwärme noch
beschließen sollten und haben wir auch
dementsprechend gemacht
lieber Kollege des parlamentarische
Verfahren wurde somit auch eingehalten
aber ob die parlamentarische Diskussion
möglich war im Vorfeld das steht wieder
auf einem ganz anderen Papier aber
aber nichtsdestotrotz einer
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas und
Fernwärme können wir als Union guten
Gewissens zustimmen obwohl sie unseren
Antrag zur Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer
auf Gasstrom und man hörte Fernwärme im
Februar noch abgelehnt haben freut es
mich umso mehr dass sie nun zur Einsicht
gekommen sind und
unsere Lösungen akzeptieren und somit
auch bis heute abschließend beschlossen
werden schau dir eigentlich dass so viel
Zeit verloren gegangen ist es geht nicht
um die Zeit die wir im Plenum verloren
haben sondern es geht um das Geld der
Menschen in unserem Land das in dieser
Zeit verplempert worden ist
etwas weniger Zeit haben sie gebraucht
um einzusehen dass zumindest zwei
Atomkraftwerke jetzt auch zumindest im
streckbetrieb was meines auch nicht
reichen wird weiter betrieben werden
weil folgelösungen für Gas und Öl noch
nicht vorliegen sinnvoll und notwendig
bei dem derzeit wachsenden Strombedarf
wäre es auch das dritte dafür in Frage
kommende Atomkraftwerk in Niedersachsen
ebenfalls weiterlaufen zu lassen aber
wer weiß was wer weiß was dann nach der
Wahl in Niedersachsen alles noch kommt
aber dafür
aber dafür kommt ja jetzt
zumindest der strompreisdeckel oder
zumindest neben den strompreisdeckel
auch der Gaspreis Deckel was den
strompreisdeckel und des abschöpfen der
zufallsgewinne in Anführungszeichen
anbelangt da bin ich am Ende der Tage
mal gespannt wie das funktioniert und
wie auch die Verteilung funktionieren
soll welcher doppelwumms oder Triple
Wums ist am Ende der Tage werden wird
wissen wir noch nicht ich würde eher
dafür plädieren dass wir auf den
schnellsten Weg in der Europäischen
Union ein darauf einwirken dass wir die
strommarktdesign ändert nämlich das
merit
order-system ändert weil dann können wir
das Problem was den zumindest den Strom
anbelangt an der Wurzel packen und das
Konzept für die gaspreisbremse soll
vielleicht wenn man glück kommt erst
Mitte Oktober vorlegen dabei liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gibt es doch
schon brauchbare Modelle auch bei den
Nachbarländern die sie oft auch zitieren
kommen wir aber zum weiteren Punkt der
noch angehängt worden ist an diesem
Tages Ansatzpunkt auch im Ausschuss und
auch jetzt die Steuerbefreiung der
Inflationsausgleich Sonderzahlungen der
Arbeitgeber in Höhe von 3.000 Euro ich
habe in einer meiner letzten Rede gesagt
sie schmücken sich mit fremden Federn
und auch diesmal passiert es wieder so
dass man sich mit fremden Federn
schmückt die Arbeitgeber und Arbeitgeber
werden wieder zur Kasse gebeten uns sie
werden unter Druck gesetzt natürlich ist
es etwas Gutes für alle
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer wenn
Sie einen Bonus von 3.000 Euro erhalten
aber man darf zurzeit auf keinen Fall
vergessen welche Belastungen die
Betriebe in unserem Land sowieso schon
haben neben der Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes der sich nicht nur auf die
unteren lohnschichten auswirkt sondern
eine Wirkung auch für die oberen
lohnschichten haben haben sie zu kämpfen
auch mit der Inflation haben sie zu
kämpfen mit gestörten Lieferketten haben
sie zu kämpfen mit Personalmangel aber
vor allem haben sie zu kämpfen mit
erhöhten Energiekosten und
Energiepreisen und dann das auch so noch
dazu es ist schön wie gesagt wenn man so
ein Geschenk verteilen kann aber ich
möchte jetzt meine abschließende
Redezeit dazu noch nutzen dass ich den
Betrieben in unserem Land mit ihren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern einmal
ein ganz großes Dankeschön aussprechen
denn sie sind es die dieses Chaos des
sie verursachen nämlich meistern müssen
sie sind es die wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
wollen und nicht in den Winterschlaf
gehen wollen die nicht einfach aufhören
wollen zu produzieren die sich für ihre
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
einsetzen und Lösungen überlegen damit
diese bei auch teils eingeschränkter
Produktion weiterbeschäftigt werden
können
die Betriebe die Betriebe in unserem
Land mit ihren Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern Stimmen momentan einen
Großteil unserer Wertschöpfung in
unseren Land sie schauen das weiterhin
Dienstleistungen angeboten werden können
und versuchen die mühsam gewonnenen
Fachkräfte auch zu halten und sie halten
dahingehend auch unser Land zusammen und
Liebe Bundesregierung ich appelliere an
Sie geben Sie der Wirtschaft und den
Menschen in unserem Land eine klare
Linie nicht nur kurzfristige Änderungen
ja es steht aber noch nicht genau drin
was es am Ende der Tage bedeuten soll
also wir haben überhand den 200
Milliarden 2.5-seitiges Papier erhalten
aber wie sie es am Ende der Tage
umsetzen das wissen wir jetzt noch nicht
die Menschen haben es satt in unserem
Landes sage ich Ihnen dass Sie die
Probleme immer erst in allerletzter
Sekunde angehen vielleicht auch ein
Stück weit lösen Planungssicherheit
Planungssicherheit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Kollegen ist das was unsere Wirtschaft
und die Gesellschaft brauchen sorgen sie
für Energiesicherheit in unserem Land
sorgen sie für den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze in dem genug Energie
vorhanden ist um alle produktionsstränge
aufrecht zu erhalten zu können und damit
einen Anstieg der Arbeitslosigkeit zu
verhindern und den Wohlstand in unserem
Land beizubehalten dankeschön
Alois rainer hat es angesprochen neben
der umsatzsteuersenkung auf Gas und
Fernwärme übrigens auch 14 Prozent der
Haushalte in Deutschland will mit
Fernwärme Betrieben beheizbaron ist es
so dass in diesem Gesetz hier heute auch
der Posten verabschiedet wird das
Arbeitgeber einen Bonus 3000 Euro
steuerfrei auszahlen können
Carlos Casper für die SPD in ihrer Rede
gesagt wir machen die Politik wegen
unseres Chaos dass wir verursacht haben
ich möchte an dieser Stelle nochmal
erinnern dass es ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender war der im März
nordsteam eins schließen wollte mit
allen Konsequenzen mit leeren
gasspeichern vor diesen Winter mit
horrenden Gaspreisen und sie haben keine
Lösung für diese Probleme das hat man an
ihren Redebeiträgen gerade gemerkt
aber warum machen wir heute diese
Politik um was geht es denn bei dieser
Politik es geht um die Bäcker die
Existenznöte haben weil ihre Gasrechnung
zu hoch sind es geht um die Bäcker die
Angst haben weil sie keinen Brot mehr
backen können und wenn dann nur noch zu
solchen Preisen dieses niemand mehr
leisten kann es geht um die Unternehmen
es geht beispielsweise um Unternehmen
der Chemieindustrie die in meinen
Wahlkreis Vorprodukte führt
Desinfektionsmittel herstellen es geht
um den schulcaterer der Angst hat vor
der Insolvenz und wird dieser Insolvenz
einhergehen würde das Kinder kein warmes
Mittagessen mehr hätten es geht um die
Familie die einfach Angst hat dass Sie
Ihre Heizkosten nicht zahlen kann und
genau für diese Menschen da draußen für
die Leute im Land machen wir heute diese
Politik
deswegen führen wir die Gas und
Strompreise ein wir greifen ein in den
Markt und stoppen die exportierenden
Energiekosten belegen 200 Milliarden
Euro auf den Tisch damit die
gaspreisbremse endlich kommt und mit ihr
die Existenznöte gehen
mit dem Abwehrschirm setzen wir den
steigenden Energiekosten etwas entgegen
und filtern die schwersten Folgen für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher sowie
für Unternehmen ab niemand muss Angst
haben in diesem Winter zu frieren
niemand muss Angst haben seinen
Arbeitsplatz zu verlieren niemand muss
Angst haben dass unsere Wirtschaft diese
Krise nicht übersteht es gilt was der
Kanzler gesagt hat you will never walk
alone
und auch dieses Gesetz dass wir heute in
zweiter dritte Lesung beschließen ist
ein weiterer Beweis dass wir den
Menschen gezielt unter die Arme greifen
mit weiteren 13 Milliarden Euro
bekämpfen wir die exorbitanten
Energiepreise und senken die
Mehrwertsteuer auf
gas-angst hat haben muss vor einer
kalten Wohnung und deswegen ist dieses
Gesetz zur Mehrwertsteuersenkung so
wichtig denn es betrifft eben nicht nur
Menschen mit kleinerem Einkommen die
Energiekrise betrifft auch den
Mittelstand das Handwerk und Unternehmen
generell dieses Gesetz ist eine ganz
direkte Antwort darauf dass viele
Anbieter von ihren Kundinnen und Kunden
bereits hochrente Abschlagszahlungen
gefordert haben diese sind hinfällig und
müssen zurückgenommen werden
und ganz besonders möchte ich
hervorheben dass wir auch die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Fernwärme senken das
ist insbesondere für die Menschen im
Osten wichtig denn dort gibt es ein gut
ausgebautes Fernwärmenetz durch das
viele Wohnungen in Ostdeutschland
beliefert werden in Dresden sind es 40
Prozent in Zwickau sind es sogar fast 50
Prozent die Ihre Heizung mit Fernwärme
betreiben so schaffen wir eine gerechte
Entlastung für ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung und auch das sollte nicht
unerwähnt bleiben es war die
SPD-Fraktion die sich am Anfang des
Monats bei ihrer Klausuren Dresden
festgelegt hat dass wir in den
markteingreifen müssen um diese enorm
Energiepreise zu deckeln es war die
SPD-Fraktion die unverschämte Gewinne
abschöpfen will und es ist die
SPD-Fraktion die nicht nur Papiere
schreibt sondern diese Politik in
Gesetzesform gießt
das Land ist im krisenmodus Krise heißt
für die Politik handeln Dinge abwägen
und Entscheidungen treffen das tun wir
als andere Regierung mit vielen Gesetzen
wir beschließen heute dass wir den
Arbeitgebern in diesem Land ermöglichen
an ihren Beschäftigten 3000 Euro Steuer
und sozialabgabenfrei zu zahlen dieses
Geld kann gestaffelt bis 2024 ausgezahlt
werden und hilft gezielt der arbeitenden
Mitte der Gesellschaft aber auch mit der
energiepreispauschale die jetzt mit dem
September Lohn ausgezahlt wird helfen
wir den Beschäftigten in diesem Land und
auch die Rentner und Rentner sowie die
Studierenden profitieren von unserer
Politik außerdem helfen wir das Wohngeld
und spannen mit dem neuen Bürgergeld ein
starkes soziales Netz auch
und wisst ihr was heute ist heute ist
der 30.09 heute ist der letzte Tag an
dem unverschämte Löhne gezahlt werden ab
morgen bekommen in meinem Wahlkreis
allein 50.000 Menschen mehr lohnen ab
morgen geht der Mindestlohn von 12 Euro
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr Sebastian Schäfer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit 200
Milliarden Euro als Abwehrschirm gegen
die Energiekrise handeln wir
entschlossen wir halten unser Land in
dieser schwierigen Zeit zusammen wir
ergeben unseren Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Sicherheit indem wir jetzt den Anstieg
der Energiepreise für Strom und Wärme so
deutlich begrenzen und wir geben damit
unseren Unternehmen unserer
mittelständischen Industrie unserem
Handwerk ein klares Signal den Kern
unserer Volkswirtschaft den Kern unseres
Wohlstands lassen wir von einem
russischen Diktator nicht zerstören
wir lassen uns
nicht erschüttern nicht einschüchtern
als DemokratInnen und Demokraten in
diesem Land
200 Milliarden
sind dann mächtiger Schutzschirm mit dem
wir dafür sorgen dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger der Mittelstand das Handwerk
aber auch soziale Einrichtungen
Kindergärten Pflegeheime sicher durch
den Winter kommen
zusätzlich entlasten wir die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger durch die Senkung der
Umsatzsteuer für Gas und Fernwärme um
einen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag das
ist erheblich und das hilft sehr direkt
als
Finanz- und Haushaltspolitiker Schmerzen
mich 200 Milliarden Euro neue Schulden
sehr ganz besonders wenn das Geld im
Wesentlichen für fossile Energie
ausgegeben wird wir begleichen damit
einen Teil der Rechnung die wir für
unsere Abhängigkeit von Putins Gas
bezahlen müssen
das sind ihre Schulden sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
das sind die Konsequenzen ihrer
Zechprellerei die wir jetzt übernehmen
müssen
wir werden die gaspreisbremse so
konstruieren dass der Anreiz zum
Energiesparen erhalten bleibt das hat
Veronika Grimm die der Kommission zur
gaspreisbremse vorsitzt heute in der FAZ
sehr deutlich unterstrichen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir jetzt
auch zusätzliche Energieeffizienz und
erneuerbare Energien investieren denn
ein zurück zu billigen fossilen Energien
die nie billig waren wird es nicht geben
unsere Wirtschaft hat bei der Effizienz
schon große Fortschritte gemacht und
nutzt Effizienzverbesserungen wo sie
kann auch viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sind solidarisch und tun was sie können
um jetzt Energie zu sparen
mit der aktuellen Überarbeitung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes legen wir
erneut etwas vor wir werden es später in
der Debatte hören das sind Ausbau und
die Nutzung der erneuerbaren Energien
noch einmal erheblich steigern wird der
biogasdeckel wird wegfallen und es wird
noch bessere Möglichkeiten für Solar und
PV-Anlagen geben auch steuerlich setzen
wir da neue Anreize und lösen endlich
bürokratische fesseln
erneuerbare Energien sind der beste Weg
um unsere Energieversorgung in
Deutschland abzusichern
so machen wir uns in und nach dieser
Krise unabhängiger von teuren Importen
von Gas Öl oder Kohle und schützen
obendrein das Klima
denn wir
wollen keine Zechprellerei auf Kosten
künftiger Generationen betreiben deshalb
machen wir in dieser
fortschrittskoalition unser Land auch in
schwierigen Zeiten zukunftsfest
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
parsa Mavi
ist Mitglied im Finanzausschuss für die
SPD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den
vergangenen Wochen erleben wir alle die
in den Wahlkreisen unterwegs sind bei
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern bei den
Betrieben bei den Sportvereinen bei den
sozialen Einrichtungen eine Menge
Verunsicherung angesichts bereits
eingegangener Energie
abschlagsforderungen die zum Teil
mehrere hundert Prozent über den
bisherigen Niveau liegen oder erwarteter
signifikante teurerung gleichzeitig
erleben wir eine Abkühlung
wirtschaftliche Indikatoren die auf eine
schwierige die auf schwierige kommende
Monate hindeuten das ist eine kritische
Situation die einer nationalen
gemeinsamen nationalen
Kraftanstrengungen Bedarf zu der wir ja
heute schon einiges von der Opposition
gehört haben und die eine entschlossenen
und konsequenten Antwort durch die
politikbedarf die diese Bundesregierung
gestern erneut eindrucksvoll geliefert
hat mit einer großen Geschlossenheit
zwischen Olaf Scholz Christian lindern
Robert Habeck zwischen den ampelpartnern
das war gestern ein whatever it
takesmoment ein ganz wichtiges Signal in
das Land hinein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
diese Bundesregierung die Ampelkoalition
befindet sich seit ihrem Amtsantritt und
insbesondere seit der Zeiten Wende vom
24 februar in permanenten krisenmodus
wir wissen dass es Angesicht sich
ständig verändernder lagen auf die wir
stetige und angemessen reagieren müssen
neben einer strategischen Orientierung
eine ordentlichen Portion
pragmatismusbedarf um dieser Krise
entgegen zu wirken Eigenschaften auf die
die Union eigentlich über viele Jahre
bei ihrer krisenkanzlerin Angela Merkel
stolz war aber diese 16 Jahre scheinen
ja schon lange her zu sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
seit Monaten seit Monaten steht diese
Ampelkoalition voll auf dem Platz mit
einfach doppelwurms und wenn es sein
muss auch dreifachwumms wir liefern und
bringen Monat für Monat Plenarwoche für
Plenarwoche Gesetze durch das Parlament
und wir haben eine vollhandlungsfähige
Bundesregierung was
was ist in diesem turbulenten ja nicht
schon alles geschehen oder auf dem Weg
meine Kollegen haben es vorhin
angedeutet die staatliche Rettung von
Juniper das erste Entlastungspaket im
ersten Halbjahr mit über 30 Milliarden
Euro die Einigung im Koalitionsausschuss
Anfang September mit Entlassung über 65
Milliarden Euro Direktzahlungen die
Eindämmung der kalten Progression die
große wohngeldreform die Anhebung des
Grundfreibetrags und vieles mehr und
jetzt in dieser Woche die entscheidenden
Damen und Herren Sie sehen es in dem
kleinen Fenster
Karl Lauterbach und Lothar Wieler der
RKI-Präsident und der Bundesminister
haben hier Platz genommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz Corona ist ein
bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten wenn
ich das richtig gelesen habe haben wir
mittlerweile mehr Tote in diesem Herbst
als vor einem Jahr also nicht zu
unterschätzen und deswegen wollen wir
Ihnen diese Pressekonferenz hier heute
morgen übertragen wir kommen dann
nachher wieder hierhin zurück in den
Deutschen Bundestag